[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
dominique bussereau bonjour bonjour être
avec nous au président du département de
la charente-maritime président de
l'assemblée des départements de france
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représenté
partout tels bertrand du groupe la
dépêche bonjour kessel bonjour bonjour
dominique visse trop beaux jours
dominique bussereau on commence bien sûr
en parlant de la stratégie vaccinale
olivier ferrand qui a échangé hier avec
les représentants des associations
d'élus les maires les régions et les
départements
que vous a dit le ministre de la santé
oms est passée cet échange ba le le
dispositif continue de se déployer
pardonnez-moi notre sentiment c'est que
ça devrait aller plus vite tendance un
peu à dire en bon charente et que c'est
à la vitesse c'est ce qu'on appelle la
cagouille c'est à dire en français
normal l'escargot bon mais c'est comme
ça et donc tous nous essayons les
collectivités de dire au gouvernement
fait plus de centres essayer d'aller
plus vite pour les plus de 75 ans pour
le plus de 70 ans + 65 ans mettez les
médecins généralistes dans la boucle
vous n'allez pas rassuré les pharmaciens
dans la boucle c'est pas que je pars
rassurer je trouve mais c'est partout en
europe le sentiment et est le même dans
tous les pays européens que ça pour
aller plus vite après je suis conscient
des difficultés je suis conscient de la
logistique du premier vaccin qui est
complexe en terme de froid de transport
de conservation voilà donc je veux pas
faire de la démagogie
mais comme tous les français on souhaite
sortir de cette période épouvantable
pour notre économie pour la vie sociale
pour la vie psychique je pense aux aux
étudiants isolé en ce moment qui qui qui
n'ont pas vu un prof depuis près d'un an
et pour tout ça il faut que le
gouvernement passe la surmultipliée en
matière de vaccination s'il le peut et
doit lui demandons de le faire dès qu'il
le pourra
l'association des départements de france
a proposé son aide logistique au
gouvernement à plusieurs reprises est ce
que vous avez eu des réponses là dessus
ça dépend ça dépend des préfets c'était
dans chaque département
il ya donc l'autorité régionale de santé
au niveau régional qui coordonne et qui
fixe les règles et puis après le
gouvernement a heureusement 10 sont les
préfets dans chaque département qui
prennent les choses en main ok les
préfets qui sont déjà réunis avec le
maire le président du département la
présidente chez eux qui ont monté des
centres de vaccination nombreux sur le
territoire
voilà il ya des endroits où les
chaussons partie partie parfois
théoriquement s'il n'y a pas les doses
pour ouvrir réellement ces centres de
vaccination et puis il ya des endroits
où les choses vont moins vite sont plus
centralisée donc plus on ira sur le
terrain plus on sera efficace donc le
message que nous passons entre
guillemets ou gouvernement s'est fait
confiance aux collectivités non pas pour
faire la politique de la santé à votre
place
et pour faire la vaccination pour tous
ensemble le plus vite possible
elle suit vous avez le sentiment d'être
entendu sur entendu mardi
je vous le dirai dans quelque temps si
nous sommes réellement écouté mais vous
avez toujours le sentiment aujourd'hui
qui ne vous fait pas confiance c'est pas
ça saoule et on a une administration
française de la santé très particulière
extrêmement centralisé
on a bien vu d'ailleurs c'était d'ici au
sénat dans la commission denquête
s'était dit à l'assemblée nationale
françois baroin renaud muselier moi
l'avons dit à plusieurs reprises
conjointement
il ya eu un vrai défaut de
fonctionnement des autorités régionales
de santé pendant le printemps dernier
alors peut-être à l'exception du de
france où j'ai moins entendu là et
résulte de france est critiquée par les
présidents département est partout en
france
il ya eu des problèmes qui ont même
conduit au départ précipité d'un patron
des récents dans une région française
dans le vente est donc c'était vraiment
hyper centralisé je sais déjà donner cet
exemple votre antenne j'ai eu 14 morts
dans un ehpad de mon département
ni le préfet ni le maire de la commune
ni l'autorité de cotutelle des ehpad qui
est le département nous n'étions au
courant
voilà donc aujourd'hui c'est mieux
aujourd'hui la rs drs ont appris à mieux
parler plus parler avec les élus mais il
n'en reste pas moins que les comités
théodule missana santé sont très
nombreux
exactement d'ailleurs qui fait quoi
laisser laval souci des responsables
voulaient qu'on les connaît un peu ils
partent et donc ça pourrait fonctionner
de manière moins centralisée moins
bureaucratique
je mets pas en doute la bonne volonté de
jean castex d'olivier ferrand je dis
qu'il faut que ça aille plus vite et
qu'on mette de l'huile dans les rouages
et les collectivités peuvent être cette
huile là alors concrètement qu'est ce
que peuvent faire les départements pour
aider de la fête par exemple je vous
avez l'exemple de mon département
lâchant pas été nous avons des médecins
des infirmiers dans nos services pour
les différentes politiques sociales que
nous menons donc tous les mettons à
disposition de la rs pour participer aux
opérations de vaccination
il ya également dans les corps de
pompiers les services départementaux
d'incendié et de secours des médecins
des pharmaciens des infirmiers qui
peuvent également participer
nous avons tous les moyens de transport
qu'ils peuvent participer à la
logistique ce soit nos services des
routes que ce second véhicule de
pompiers nous avons les lieux les
gymnases des collèges de tous nos
centres sociaux voilà donc nous mettons
ça avec les maires évidemment les mieux
placés pour donner des choses pratiques
sur les mers dans leur commune mais nous
pouvons fournir une enveloppe globale de
régulation et d'accélération à l'échelle
d'un départ tout est alors on se parle
aucun de vos personnels départementale
n'est sollicitée alors pour l'instant
nous avons dit au préfet qu'ils étaient
prêts nous les avons prévenus et ils
sont prêts dès que y aura les nos deux
doses nécessaires
ils sont prêts à participer à des
opérations sur le terrain dans un
département comme le mien au départ il y
avait un centre d'appui 2 est
aujourd'hui que le préfet nous sommes
mis d'accord sur entre 6 et 10 centres
qui pourrait être avoir lieu sur le
département mais faut-il encore qu'il y
ait des doses
et puis que les gens peuvent accéder a
vu ce qui s'est passé dans six ou où ça
s'est accéléré et tant mieux pour les
nancéens
mais aussi les gens cherchent à tricher
second 74 ans et demi 73 me 72 et demi
et donc c'est très compliqué à gérer ce
séquençage si j'ose dire de la
population c'est pas séquençage du
génome cette fois ci est très compliqué
à gérer et parfois incompréhensibles
parce qu'ils pourront peut être en
pleine forme à 75 ans est très fatigué à
70 ans
à vous écouter on a l'impression que ces
discussions ont lieu actuel en
permanence 1 alors que en allemagne en
espagne
tout ça a été étudié en amont dès début
décembre
est ce que l'un des noeuds du problème
se situe là et ce qui a eu une
défaillance même bertrand c'est pas la
tradition française la tradition
française c'est l'état c'est et les
collectivités ne savent pas où ça va
moins où ça va moins bien
donc ce que vous essayez de dire c'est
que nous ne voulons pas prendre la place
de l'état pendant une opération de gérer
de sécurité nationale du pays mais que
nous nous sommes prêts à faire en sorte
que ça s'accélère parce que nous avons
les moyens que l'état d'âme mais elles
ont elles ont lieu progressivement métro
progressivement et c'est le moi ce que
je souhaite si vous laissez pas qu'il
discute pas c'est bien qu'ils aient des
discussions nationales où je faisais
lisons tout à l'heure et plus ministre
avec le premier ministre les pièces etc
et discussions locales dire que dans le
département d'indre et loire à tours le
préfet le président du département le
maire
les maires des grandes villes et
intercos mettent autour d'une table avec
la rs ont dit voilà comment on fait dans
l'indre et loire ou comment faire
charente maritime etc
c'est ça qui est important c'est pas les
discussions dans les ministères à paris
sur les principes où on nous raconte à
peu près toujours la même chose à votre
volonté là c'est sur le terrain que les
choses se passent vous évoquez la
question des doses est ce que vous savez
exactement combien de doses on arrivait
chez vous est ce que tous n'ont infléchi
annoncé qu'au départ il ya eu cinq mille
partout alors c'est c'était d'ailleurs
là encore le centralisme à la française
1 sa mise en lozère comme 5000 ans dans
le nord on gironde et maintenance est en
train de se développer mais alors là on
sa formation sont connus localement en
mobilité
on nous dit que ça arrive bien qu'il ya
des livraisons régulières etc
mais je suis incapable de vous donner
les chiffres ce qu'il faut c'est un
effet beaucoup de doses
il ya deux vaccins qui sont déjà
acceptés peut-être un troisième
peut-être d'autres encore voilà si on
veut que la france vive normalement 2021
j'y vais ce matin dans je vous confrères
des échos
la grande inquiétude de bruno le maire
que le taux de croissance de 6% qui est
très ambitieux affichés pour 2021 soit
tenue si on veut que l'économie reparte
je veux que la vie des français soient
moins morose soit moins gris soit moins
froide
il faut absolument développer la
vaccination pour aboutir au maximum
d'humidité dans notre pays alors se
ferait la vaccination on en veut pas
comment ça se passe dans votre
département de la charente maritime est
ce que est ce que vous les sentez ses
réticences aussi bien chez les résidents
notamment des pâtes qui peuvent
commencer à se faire vacciner que chez
les plus de 75 ans qui vont pouvoir
commencer lundi que chez les personnels
soignants brigitte bourguignon yaren
nous disait qu'il ya des endroits où
seulement 20% des tgv que j'ai vu ce
chiffre également cité par rue gilles
bourguignon sur le jeu prendre un
exemple très simple
papa qu'elle 97,1 dans un ehpad l'ehpad
m'a demandé puisque je suis sa personne
morale de référence si j'acceptais après
qu'il ait eu un examen que son médecin
donc l'examen que le médecin d'avoir
lieu
j'ai bien sûr dit oui mais ce que je
sais maintenant cet ehpad mais dans
d'autres c'est qu'il ya une partie du
personnel qui ne veut pas se faire
vacciner
faut voir aussi les ehpad ont des
grosses difficultés de recrutement ils
sont un personnel permanent mais sont
sans arrêt obligé de faire appel à des
intérimaires parce que ce métier de
femmes et d'hommes au contact de
personnes très âgées est extrêmement
difficile donc il est possible que dans
ces populations-là moins informés il ya
des réticences le vaccin donc ses
classiques en france un mois je quand
j'étais enfant
c'est l'époque on se vacciner contre la
polio le dcg cetera
il y avait des parents qui ne voulaient
pas faire vacciner leurs enfants donc
c'est un fait récurrent dans tous les
pays et du coup il ya eu des vaccins
obligatoires est ce qu'il faudrait le
rendre obligatoire ces vaccins pour les
soignants je ne suis
mais je ne suis jamais pour le vaccin
obligatoire tous ne les ai pas beaucoup
de personnes n'ont pas véritablement
leur discernement pour les soignants
dans les ehpad
ça pourrait être ça pourrait être ça
pourrait l'être mais je ne suis pas sûr
que les différentes juridictions
l'acceptent
merci avait des recours devant la
justice civile ou la justice
administrative
je suis pas sûr que le ce qui rendrait
la vaccination obligatoire l'emportent
ça reste un domaine de la dda personnes
privées dans notre pays même si
personnellement je ne comprends pas
qu'on refuse la vaccination mais voilà
c'est des choses qui les choses qui ne
s'expliquent pas malheureusement est ce
qu'il faudrait que les élus donnent
l'exemple est ce que ça pourrait avoir
un impact si vous voulez les élus sur
toujours préfère prendre en photo ou est
sur un plateau télévision en train de se
faire piquer donc ça vous aurez tous les
élus de france surtout ceux qui sont
candidats aux prochaines élections
départementales et régionales qui
dérange à vacciner
pas sûr que ça change la face des choses
il faudrait mieux que ce soit en direct
stéphane bern ou où quelques uns de vos
confrères et vous-même de la télévision
de la radio connu des français qu'ils se
fassent vacciner plus tôt que leurs élus
dans tout le monde pensera qu'il a voulu
faire une opération de publicité et qu'à
la limite il y avait de l'eau simplement
dans le la seringue ont parlé des
personnes isolées
dans parmi les personnes isolées il ya
les personnes âgées notamment l
isolement s'est accrue de ses personnels
avec la crise sanitaire est ce que vous
attendez des choses du gouvernement sur
ce sujet pour aider ces personnes âgées
isolées soul et le gouvernement peut pas
grand-chose personnes isolées en ehpad
bon là c'était très dur pendant le
premier confinement puisqu'ils étaient
bloqués dans leur chambre pouvait pas
voir de repas en commun d'animation et
c'est donc là s'entraîner une détresse
psychologique et parfois une une
détérioration de leur état psychique
importante
là les choses sont plus souples dans les
ehpad ça dépend évidemment des régions
mais les visites sont autorisés à faire
des choses sont plus souples
après les mieux placés pour le faire
sont les collectivités c'est à dire les
mène en particulier les maires nous
avons dans chaque commune depuis la
grande canicule à ficher les personnes
en difficulté enfin les personnes très
âgées seules en les appelant en
organisant des visites avec le monde
associatif et cetera fonds pour leur
isolement mais je prends un exemple
inverse les étudiants moi je j'enseigne
à sciences po je ne pas voir cette année
deux visages des étudiants je vais les
voir sur zoom ou sur steam ce je ne sais
pas encore et ceux qui sont provinciaux
étrangers qui sont à paris dans une
chambre de bonne dans un petit studio 1
des résidences universitaires qui ne
voit personne par leur ordinateur ou
leur tablette pendant la journée
pas de contacts sociaux pas de contacts
amicaux tout ce qui fait la vie
étudiante et et son charme
je n'ai que des examens passés dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles et
parfois sans vraie valeur de l'examen
intermédiaire je trouve que là il ya un
problème qu'il faut traiter le plus
rapidement parce qu'on est en train de
faire deux ou trois générations
d'étudiants qui seront complètement
désaxé et pas formés comme il le faut et
psychiquement difficulté qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire vous dites très faible après
on peut faire par exemple je vois chez
moi de lui verser de la rochelle la des
associations la ville d'autres
collectivités organisent des
distributions de repas essaye
d'organiser des
et des rencontres à l'extérieur où le
moins les gens peuvent se parlent
échangent et cetera il faut que chacun
puisse prendre une initiative
c'est pas disait-il personnel s'était
privé vis-à-vis de deux jeux de gens qui
habitent près de chez vous des étudiants
de jeunes que vous connaissez mes mais
voilà la détresse des personnes âgées
malheureusement les constantes vous êtes
dans un ehpad puis 95 en est pas
forcément heureux mais que des gens de
20 ans au moment ils apprennent où ils
vont rentrer dans la vie où ils sont en
pleine éclosion soit profondément
malheureux c'est évidemment très
attristant alors un des lourds dossiers
que les départements des traités c'est
les mineurs isolés aussi comment ça se
passe avec eux s'ils voulaient en 2020
nous avons eu moins d'entrées de mineurs
non accompagnés
1 pourquoi parce que les frontières
étaient fermées plus plus gardés par la
police aux frontières parler les pays
européens qui nous en tirons particulier
l'allemagne et de l'italie pardon à
l'espagne parce qu'elle ait pas de vols
les gens paient pas dire en avion il n'y
a pas de train pas plus dans les pays
qui nous entourent que chez nous donc le
flux s'est tari 1 c'est bien combien on
n'a pas de chiffres sur 2020 sur 2019
on a des chiffres de 2,2 de gens
accueillis par la zone l'aide sociale à
l'enfance de gens estimé on les gens les
gens de gens évaluent et pardon aux
alentours de 40 milles
mais simplement dette sociale à
l'enfance environ 11 milles
il ya des gens qui bougent et les gens
qui se font pas connaître il ya des gens
qui essayent de passer d'un département
à l'autre très difficile ce qu'on sait
c'est qu'en 2020 y avait eu moins à
cause de la pandémie
après il ya toujours des problèmes
d'accueil d'avoir auprès de coups parce
que
l'état nous donne généreusement 6000
euros alors que le coût annuel d'un
garçon que nous devons faire vivre
nourrir loger
formé à billets et de ghor helmand de
50000 euros par an bon ça c'est l'aspect
financier c'est un peu un peu rustre
mais enfin c'est pas rien et puis elle
le fait ensuite de l'est de pouvoir les
accueillir et des polémiques parfois sur
les conditions d'accueil et cetera tous
les départements essaye de faire leur
boulot c'est très compliqué faut bien
savoir qu'au départ c'est une
énumération déguisé c'est une famille
quelque part ou burkina qui décide que
seront fils qu'est le plus résistant le
plus intelligent le plus travailleur de
la famille va par un réseau de passeurs
arrivée en france
donc ce sont des gens qui viennent pour
s'intégrer je mets à part une ce qui se
passe en région parisienne avec des
bandes de jeunes en particulier issus du
maroc qui viennent pour des raisons de
de s'organiser en réseaux de délinquance
générale ce qui arrive dans l'est dans
nos provinces sont des africains qui
viennent pour apprendre un métier
s'intégrer ensuite faire venir leurs
familles c'est quand même une
immigration déguisés et je vois bien que
un sur quatre est un vrai mineurs et que
trois sur quatre mais c'est de se faire
passer pour mineurs et après c'est très
compliqué détecter parce que les
analyses osseuse ne sont pas toujours
fiables et donc c'est le travail des
éducateurs d'essayer de trouver la
vérité mais il avait clairement émis
leurs conditions d'hébergement se sont
compliquées pas vraiment parce que s'ils
voulaient nos foyers nos enfants sont
restés ouverts dans ses foyers nous
avons également les jeunes de deux
familles de nos départements qui sont
séparés les parents sont en difficulté
alcoolisme violence et c'est donc les
structures d'hébergement sont restés le
monde associatif continue de faire un
travail tout à fait remarquable en la
matière alors on les a il sont pas
allées des structures n'ont pas fermé
simplement ça rajouter des difficultés
aux difficultés quand même sur le coup
parce qu'il est important c'est les 2
milliards le reste à charge
nous estimons emmanuel macron s'était
engagé à prendre intégralement en charge
le coût de ces mineurs isolés
aujourd'hui la prise en charge à lait
d'environ 14% est ce que vous croyez
encore au fait qu emmanuel macron va
tenir sa promesse ou est-ce que
malheureusement pour un sou
les yeux dans les yeux et je pense avec
beaucoup de sincérité à un moment il a
prononcé cette phrase je vais en prendre
le coût total parce que c'est la
politique de l'état c'est le méritaient
politique régaliennes d'immigration la
réalité sont les chiffres que je
rappeler à l'instant 6000 euros
cinquante mille euros donc plus l'état
fera d'efforts
mieux on se portera financièrement et
mieux mais il ya encore d'autres moyens
discussion là dessus avec l'état ou pas
du tout lui on lui rappelle de manière
sempiternelle et de manière sempiternel
on nous dit qu'on va s'en occuper mais
vous y croyez avant la fin du
quinquennat
je le touche du bois autre sujet c'est
le rsa le rsa le nombre d'allocataires
du rsa il était d'à peu près 2 million
avant le début de la crise aujourd'hui
vous l'estimez à combien on imagine
écoutez on a faim on attend encore les
chiffres mais on voit par département
des augmentations qui vont de 5 à 15 20
% depuis le printemps avec une
augmentation à l'automne et notre
crainte c'est 2021 on voit bien il
suffit de se promener dans une rue d'une
de nos vies n'a pas ri ou n'importe
quelle ville de france pour voir les
magasins qui ferment qui liquide les
bistrots ne devrait pas sûr que pour
certains ils vont pouvoir et ouvrir ou
les petits restaurants même les grands
et donc on a peur d'avoir toute une
série d'hommes et de femmes qui vont
arriver au rsa parce qu'ils sont trop
âgés pour reprendre un travail où le
marché d'emploi n'offrira pas donc notre
prévision c'est une augmentation très
importante du rsa en 2021
ce qui pose les mêmes questions
d'habitude un comme on essaye de
réinsérer ces gens est ce que reste au
rsa advitam eternam
ou est ce qu'on essaie de les en sortir
en tout cas pour les plus jeunes et ceux
qui peuvent entrer son marché de
l'emploi et deux jours le coup parce que
évidemment l'état ne paie qu'à peu près
la moitié 1 2 du coup dur et ça le reste
est à la charge des départements et donc
nous le monde et a fait quelques pris
quelques mesures sympathique dans le
budget enfin d'un projet de loi de
finances pour 2021 mais qui sont pas
naturellement la hauteur de la situation
donc nous allons réinterroger l'état
tout au long de l'année 2021 ce sera
l'un des sujets du bureau de l'adf qui
se réunit dans quelques jours en disant
prenez plus anciens de rsa parce que
sinon vous allez avoir des départements
qui vont repartir vers une situation de
faiblesse financière
ce sont des dépenses de fonctionnement
quand vos dépenses de fonctionnement
augmentent va vous diminuez
l'investissement commande ou demande en
même temps de faire de la relance
d'investir plus plus vite et mieux si on
a moins de ressources pour à cause du
rsa et d'autres d'autres charges
sociales on ne pourra pas participer à
la relance du coup ça remet sur la table
la question de la renationalisation de
crs est ce que vous êtes falloir un
gouvernement
elle nous avons nous avons convenu avec
le gouvernement que les départements
volontaires pourraient le faire pourrait
profiter l'année 2021 pour discuter avec
le gouvernement des modalités le faire
pour l'instant la seine saint denis
quelques autres se sont portés
volontaires
faut-il encore que leurs discussions
aboutissent car je vous rappelle que
enfin vous savez nous avions discuté
avec le gouvernement valls par exemple
au dessus sommes allés très loin
puis nous avons buté sur l'année de
référence parce que bercy s'était mis en
travers et on nous propose un système
qui était inique
donc j'espère que les négociations des
quelques départements volontaires c'est
qu'à tout 5,1 sur la centaine de
départements français aboutiront et
qu'il n'y aura pas les mêmes réticences
financières pour leur permettre cette
renationalisation qui existe déjà dans
les départements d'outre-mer en
difficulté je pensais la guyane et la
réunion en particulier puisque vous
parlez la seine saint denis son
président stéphane troussel et ils
demandent l'ouverture du rsa aux moins
de 25 ans est ce que vous êtes favorable
c'est une revendication classique de la
gauche socialiste
ça tombe de l'eau collègues présents
département porte également l'idée d'un
revenu universel
c'est je trouve c'est assez dangereux
c'est assez dangereux parce que ça peut
ça peut faire en sorte que personne
beaucoup de gens ne finalement le
cherche pas à rentrer sur le marché du
travail avant à cause du rsa
ceci étant si la détresse sociale le
persiste et si la détresse des étudiants
persiste et il faudrait trouver des
moyens financiers d'aider un certain
nombre de jeunes à sortir de ses
difficultés qui ne serait pas le rsa qui
seront peut-être une allocation génèse
spécifie pendant un certain temps
pendant la crise en fonction d'un
certain nombre de cas sociaux et
dernière question vous ne serez pas
candidat aux prochaines dans des
élections départementales
vous quittez la politique non non si
vous voulez moi j'ai la chance d'être
élu pour la première fois élu municipal
en 1983 vous imaginez ça fait fait fait
l'addition du nombre d'années
départemental en 85 g pour la première
fois député en 1986 mais tout ça est
quand même des années qu'ils sont qui
sont lointaines et donc je pense qu'il
ya un âge où
à partir duquel il faut plus se
présenter aux élections donc je ne me
représenterai pas en juin s'ils
tentaient que ces élections
départementales et régionales et bien
lieu au mois de juin randonnée quand on
a vécu tout au long de sa vie la passion
de la de la vie publique naturellement
on n'arrête pas donc je continuerai à
m'intéresser campagne présidentielle la
vie publique
mais je trouve que le chiffre 7 est pour
moi un chiffre important bien que je
sois tintinophiles je pourrais dire de 7
à 77 ans et moelleux politique m'a
intéressé dès l'âge de 7 ans mais je
m'arrêterai non pas 60 17 mai à 70 ans
enfin au delà de 70 ans je ne serai pas
candidat et comme j'en ai 68 pour être
très clair je ne serai pas candidat au
printemps prochain
oui on espère qu'on aura l'occasion de
vous revoir sur ce plateau mais c'est
avec bonheur avec bonheur et même après
si vous voulez que quelques sages et je
viens de vous rencontrer
serra de venir vous voir avec bonheur
merci beaucoup merci dominique bussereau
et d'avoir été avec nous ce matin merci
christelle on regarde la une de la
dépêche
quand on a un virus s'attendre au pire
on va en parler dans le club des
territoires avec eric berger et merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec nous on
va se tuer justement clubs de tête
[Musique]